SPEAKER: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for joining.
Today, as you know, we have the
fantastic and amazing Julieta
Venegas with us.
[APPLAUSE]
Just to get us
started, I would like
to talk to you a little
bit about your experience
being born and
raised in Tijuana,
then growing up,
becoming this fantastic
international artist-- Grammy
winner, known all around
the world.
Can you tell us a little
bit about that experience
and what are the key milestones
around that big journey?
JULIETA VENEGAS: OK,
first, hi, everyone.
It's great to be here.
And thank you for
this whole event.
Well, I was born in
Long Beach, actually.
I wasn't born in Tijuana.
I never lived in Long Beach.
Actually, my parents were
moving around California.
And they're both
Mexican, but they both
had their immigration papers.
But they finally
settled in Tijuana.
They grew up there and--
well, practically, yeah.
And they decided that that
was the best place to be.
And I kind of grew up very
much a border life, you know?
I mean, every time one
of my brothers or sisters
were going to be
born, we'd cross.
They'd have their kid
and go back to Tijuana.
And [SPANISH], you know?
[LAUGHTER]
So I actually grew
up in Tijuana.
But it's very much a border
life, very much bilingual.
I grew up watching
American television.
That's how I learned English.
I never studied in the US.
I did do like a
junior college when
I finished high school
because I wanted
to study a career in music.
But in Tijuana, the music
school wasn't really
that developed yet.
So I decided to try to start
getting my-- what is it called?
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
SPEAKER: Oh, like the classes?
JULIETA VENEGAS: Yeah, like
the points to get to SDSU.
SPEAKER: The credits.
JULIETA VENEGAS:
Yeah, the credits.
And I was in the middle of
that when I went to Mexico City
to visit.
And I just kind of fell
in love with the city.
I was like, I don't want
to leave this place.
It just completely--
it blew my mind.
I mean, I'd been in
big cities-- not really
that kind of big cities.
I'd been in-- I don't know, like
Los Angeles or San Francisco.
But when I got to Mexico
City, it's like part of me
completed itself.
I was always in Tijuana
thinking about Mexico.
My dad was so much about Mexico.
We were always
talking about Mexico.
But Tijuana was
not-- it was a mix.
It wasn't exactly Mexican.
It wasn't exactly US.
So when I saw Mexico City, I
decided I had to live there.
SPEAKER: Of course.
JULIETA VENEGAS: And so
I went back to Tijuana,
picked up my stuff.
And I've been there 20 years.
That's the personal side.
Musically, I started
studying classical piano
when I was eight.
My parents thought
it would be good
for us to not watch too much TV.
So they had us studying
piano and all kinds
of lessons-- ballet, painting,
whatever came to their minds.
And I was terrible
at everything.
And for some reason, I came
out being really good at music.
So I studied classical,
like-- [SPANISH].
SPEAKER: Just
individual lessons?
JULIETA VENEGAS:
Particular classes,
yeah, for like eight years.
And then I started
playing in bands.
When I was in high
school, a friend of mine
invited me to a band
as a keyboard player.
And I discovered
improvisation, and singing,
and just kind of-- it was a
completely different path.
And the important
thing for me there
was that I discovered
songwriting.
And that was basically what made
me shift my path completely.
And I started doing
songwriting after that.
And also, at the
same time I started
doing music for theater.
So it was instrumental
and it was also songs.
And so I kept on
developing that.
And then by the time
I was, what, like 22,
that's when I went
to Mexico City.
I was still kind of
searching for what I wanted.
I kept on putting bands
together because I always
thought I had to be in a band.
And it never worked out.
I always did a lot of writing
with a few different people.
And when I got to Mexico City,
I actually put like posters up
trying to get a band together.
That's the way we did
it before like internet.
You modern people
wouldn't know about that.
But I did like posters in record
stores and stuff like that.
And I put a band together.
It didn't work out either.
But in one of those shows,
I met three of the guys
from [INAUDIBLE], which
was really important for me
because I started going
out with one of them.
SPEAKER: Oh, yeah.
[LAUGHS]
JULIETA VENEGAS:
And no, but also, it
was very important
for me because he's
someone who really
influenced me in saying like,
why do you want to keep
putting bands together?
Just do your thing.
You have these great
songs in your drawer,
but you keep putting bands
together and making our songs.
And it's just like--
And I always dreamt of
getting an accordion.
It was always like my dream.
And he pushed me
into like, just get
your accordion, and your drum
machine, and leave me alone.
So I started doing
shows by myself
with just piano, accordion,
and a drum machine.
And I started opening for a
bunch of bands in Mexico City.
And I actually did
like an eight track
demo, which was a big deal.
And a lot of people started
giving it to friends.
And it kind of became like a
[? "Waka Waka." ?] Like oh,
there's this girl.
And she plays accordion.
And she sings.
And that way, I started playing
with a few musician friends.
And in those shows,
I don't know.
Things started happening really
quickly, all of a sudden.
Nothing happened for
ages, for a long time.
But then all of a sudden, people
started showing up to my shows.
And record labels
started showing up
to my shows-- people
from record labels.
Like three different record
labels were interested.
They'd heard the demo.
And one thing led to
another, and here we are.
No, I'm kidding.
SPEAKER: Fantastic.
JULIETA VENEGAS:
So I got signed.
And that was a long time ago.
That was almost, what,
like-- long time ago.
It must have been like in--
I got signed in, I think,
in '95, '96 or something.
And then after that,
it's been like-- I mean,
I put two albums that
were not so well known
outside of Mexico, which were
"Aqui" and "Bueninvento."
But I was touring a lot anyway.
But I really wanted
to tour more.
I feel like I was just kind
of touring around Mexico
but it was really
hard for me to leave.
And also, I had this sort of
revelation between my second
and my third album.
I had like a year where I
had this sort of crisis.
Like what kind of songwriter
do I really want to be?
Do I really want to be
this very experimental sort
of songwriter?
Or do I want to express and
communicate more with people?
And that was like a year
of thinking, and writing,
and having this super
crisis, and what do I want.
Because my second album had
been really critically acclaimed
but very difficult
album in every sense.
Recording it was difficult.
Touring with it was difficult.
It was just like really--
And I was like, maybe I'm
taking the wrong sort of path.
Maybe I want something
else as a songwriter.
I wanted to do songs that
connected differently
with people, not
like-- one day, I
remember being on
the stage and sort
of playing my super complicated
and wonderful songs.
And I just felt like people
were just kind of staring at me.
Like, who is this Martian?
And I just kind of wanted--
you know, I want to connect.
That's what music is,
about communication.
And that's what I wanted.
So that took a lot
of self-analyzing.
And I never believed
in analysis.
So I did my own self-analysis.
And that's how-- you
know, I started writing
"Si," which was my third album.
And that was kind
of a breakthrough.
I think that was the
first time that I actually
went into the radio,
that I started actually
sounding on the
radio, that people
were like-- a lot of people
think that's my first album.
But that's my third album.
So after that, a lot of
things have happened.
But that was
already a while ago.
That was in 2003.
So it's been while.
SPEAKER: Perfect.
And I think you're
doing a fantastic job,
just connecting with
people with your music.
You can really feel it
when you hear your songs.
And one of the themes that
I'm hearing in your career
is this sense of just
being persistent, right?
Like even if things were not
happening at the beginning,
even if there was a
try, fail, try again.
And then in the end,
it actually happened.
And it became a very
big success for you.
Can you tell us a
little bit about how
you were thinking about
this process of, I need
to get up, try again,
try something different,
redefine myself, going to
even self-analysis, which
[INAUDIBLE].
JULIETA VENEGAS: Well,
what happens, I think,
is that I really enjoy
the process of things.
I don't believe in, this is
what I have to be by this time.
This is what I-- I really love
the process of how you become
who you are, in every sense.
Even now that I've already put
out like seven or eight albums,
that I've been
touring forever, I
enjoy what I do also because I
enjoy every bit of what I do,
every different part, what
it means to do what I do,
which is every time
I finish a tour,
I dedicate myself like four
months to just writing.
I don't do anything else.
And then when I'm
touring, I just
really enjoy the tour itself.
I enjoy the shows.
I enjoy that
connection with people.
I think the important
thing is that.
It's not only to
think about how you
get to where you want
to get to, but it's just
like the whole
learning experience
and the whole learning
process, which I think
is really a constant thing.
It's not something
that starts and ends
when you get what you want.
You're always sort of
learning from what--
even when you get what you
want, it's through learning.
You still wonder if that
was the right thing.
You keep going.
And I think what I
really like to do
is to ask questions all the
time about what I really want.
And I'm very curious
about songwriting.
And I'm still curious about it,
about getting into the studio
and see what happens.
And it's not just, oh now, it's
sort of like a routine thing.
I still feel the same
nerves, the same intensity
of trying a new song and
just putting it together,
and then arranging it, and
then going to the studio
and producing it.
It's still sort of
new in a way for me.
When I start
actually doing it, I
don't feel like
I know the steps.
And I really prefer it that way.
Because I-- I don't know.
I always think that it's
better to forget what you learn
and keep learning, even
if you have to relearn.
It's actually better.
It's a better feeling.
And I've always let myself
be guided by my intuition
more than what I know, more
than what I've learned.
It's more like,
what is my instinct
telling me to do at this moment?
And that's something I
ask myself all the time.
SPEAKER: That sounds great.
And I think it's great advice.
And that's part of all this
just redefining yourself.
Just keep asking questions.
It sounds like
along the way, there
were also some opportunities
and some challenges
that you might have faced,
being Mexican American
and then just trying to break
into an international market.
Can you tell us how
you were thinking
about that process of,
oh, wait, maybe this
is becoming something big.
Or do I want to go that way?
Do I want to consolidate?
How do I wanted to think
about myself in the future
if there is not a lot
of-- I'm in point A,
and I want to get to
point B. It's more
self-reflection along the way.
How did this process
happen to you?
JULIETA VENEGAS:
Well, when I think
about my career in the sense
of maybe when I found myself,
people ask me a
lot of why I don't
sing in English, for example.
I think the language has
been something that's
been very important for me.
Because even though I
grew up in a border city,
even if I'm bilingual,
writing in Spanish to me
is much more natural.
I mean, I've never tried
writing in English, really.
And it's not something
that-- I know
that now, I see a lot of artists
who find it more natural.
And I think it's
great, especially
when you live in the US.
You speak Spanish.
You speak English.
But my mom always spoke to
me in Spanish, you know--
and my boyfriend.
My emotional life has been
constructed in [SPANISH].
So for me, writing has to
do with my own language.
So at one point, yeah, they
started asking me like,
aren't you going to
do like a crossover?
And I'm like, I
would like people
to cross over to my side.
This is my language.
This is what I celebrate
when I write a song.
And I think part of
the search for me--
because I'm influenced by
a lot of books in English,
and obviously,
musicians in English.
And the English language is very
present in my life, at least.
But when I sit
down to write, it's
more connected with my emotions.
Spanish is much more
connected to my emotions.
So I find it a lot more natural.
I think that's the
only place where
I found-- like at one
point when I put out
my fourth album, "Limon y Sal,"
it started getting super big.
And yeah, it's
starting to grow a lot.
We want to do more of Europe.
We want to go to Germany.
We want to go to Italy.
It started just kind
of growing a lot.
And at one point, things
started coming up.
Like, oh you know to sell in
Germany, you have to do this.
You have to have somebody else
do an arrangement for the song.
And you have to do this.
If you want to
sound in Portugal,
you have to do a duet with this
artist you've never even met
who you don't even know.
And you have to do it.
I was like, you know what?
Let's just let it flow.
Let it be natural.
If it's not going to happen,
it's not going to happen.
Maybe I needed an
extra bit of ambition
that I didn't really
have, because I kind of
enjoyed what I was doing.
And I was like if people
want to listen to what I
do the way I do it, it's great.
But I don't want to
sort of invent something
that I'm not to [INAUDIBLE]
in radio and somewhere else.
We eventually did go to Germany
to do a tour, and it was great.
And we are eventually
did go to Italy.
You know, eventually,
things happened.
But it didn't
happen at the point
where everybody
wanted them to happen.
Like yes, now is
the moment where
Europe is going to be
taken, that kind of thing.
I was like, I don't know.
I mean, let's just
kind of let it flow.
And let's-- I don't know.
I just don't think that
I really needed that.
And I don't call myself
non-ambitious because I am.
The fact that I'm doing music
and that I'm still doing it
now means that I guess I do.
And I think we all need
a little bit of ambition
in our lives to do
anything, anything at all.
It's like you wake
up in the morning
and you say, I want
to get up and do
something, that requires
some sort of ambition,
and sort of growing, and
learning, and all that.
But at one point, you wonder
how far you want to take things.
And I was like, this
is all that I am.
I can't be more than I am.
I can't invent
somebody that I'm not.
So this as far as I'll go.
And then we'll see what happens.
SPEAKER: Of course.
And I think the organic
growth that you're
mentioning without making a
lot of sacrifices actually
makes your music
and you as an artist
very authentic, very original.
And just taking a quick
look around the group here,
I know the majority of
us here are Latinos.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
But I even see, for
instance, people from Germany
here in the auditorium
with us, which
is really, really fantastic.
And that's part of all
this cultural interaction.
Yeah, it's funny that
you mentioned Germany.
As part of this multicultural
interaction of understanding
what's specific to
every market, what
needs to be adjusted so
that you can be successful.
As Latinos, many of us
know the big challenges
that we see-- just
going international,
being successful, sometimes
the stereotypes and all that.
And I think we're all
very conscious about that.
So rather than asking you
about those challenges,
I'd like to ask you
about the opportunities.
What do you see as an
opportunity for being Latino?
For instance, I
see in your career,
there were a lot of partnerships
along the way-- people
who, also being Latinos,
they help you along the way.
Maybe they taught you,
hey, we should do this,
or we should, I don't know, form
a band, something like that.
Can you talk a little bit
more about that positive side
that you see as something
very special and unique
of the Latino culture?
JULIETA VENEGAS:
Yeah, definitely.
I think that Latin America has--
we're all connected, not only
through our language.
But also culturally,
we're all have this--
we're all very
complex countries.
We've had very
complex histories.
And we're racially very
diverse in a different sense
than how it is here
in the United States.
I mean, in Mexico, [SPANISH].
Most countries in Latin America
are very much mixed cultures.
And we grew up with
a sort of richness
and also with all this great
history and terrible history
of conquest.
But also, that is what
made us who we are, right.
SPEAKER: Of course.
JULIETA VENEGAS: So I do think
that we have that in common.
And culturally,
that makes us very--
I think each one has their
own identity and very
proud identities.
And I mean, for
example in Mexico,
I think that we are-- I
mean I think Mexico is just
like a brilliant and amazing
and surprising country, even
with all our problems.
And I speak of
Mexico in particular
because I don't like to
speak just so generally.
At the same time,
we're very corrupt,
and we have a lot of problems.
And that's why a
lot of people just
have the need to leave and
try to make things happen
for them in a different place.
Because there's also a lot of
poverty, a lot of violence.
There's many things that make
our country a very mixed place.
It's beautiful.
I haven't been able to leave,
and I don't want to leave.
The other day,
somebody was asking me,
why don't you come
here, like to the US?
Because I have two
nationalities, right?
So it's like [SPANISH].
[LAUGHTER]
But I'm in love with that city.
I want to educate my
daughter in that country.
And I want her to be
proud of her country.
And it's a beautiful place.
It's beautiful.
And it's also
heartbreaking sometimes
to see a lot of things
that are happening.
And I've written a lot about
that in some of my songs.
And it's always
present because it's
sort of like a different
pain that you feel maybe
and a different love that
also you feel for that place,
for the people that we are.
And I think that's something
a lot of people share
in different countries in
Latin America-- that you have
this sort of love and fear,
and at the same time, hope
of the things coming together
and working out for everybody.
SPEAKER: Of course.
And being from Mexico City,
I might be slightly biased,
but I agree with you.
It's a fantastic
city to live in.
And everybody
should go and visit.
But also, there's one
thing that you touched on
that I think it's very specific
to Mexico in your example,
but it could happen in other
Latin American countries.
There is this city,
this country's
certainly not perfect.
It's far from it.
We know there are huge
problems that there
are in society, in
government, in every aspect
of everyday life.
However, that doesn't mean
you don't love the country.
That doesn't mean you don't
absolutely love the city,
and like returning there,
and like establishing
your entire life there.
And I think that's what
sets many Latin American
cultures apart.
There's this love.
There's this familiar
feeling of everywhere we go.
Could you say this has
modified, or in a way, shaped
the way you do music, the way
you think about your career
and everything, as compared to
any other international artist
you might know?
JULIETA VENEGAS: I'm not sure.
I mean, I can't really compare
myself with other artists.
I can say, oh, I
did it like this
when they did it like that.
I think everybody's music has
to do with their identity in one
way or another.
No matter what style
you make, it's personal.
It's always personal.
So it's always
about who you are,
where you're from, what's
your history like, what
you like to look at in your own
country or in other countries.
For me, making music
has to do with my root.
And that's not only
in the obvious sense,
which is like folklore
Mexican [SPANISH].
It's also, in every sense,
culturally-- the way
that I think has to do with
the fact that I'm from Tijuana
but I went to Mexico.
All my decisions have been based
on the fact that I am who I am.
And I think that music
is made that way.
Everything-- art
It's personal.
So you're kind of telling
your own story in your music.
And I can use-- for
example in a song,
I'll put it this super
Norteno accordion,
but I also like to
put in something
like a super synthesizer
and mix it up.
Because that's the
person that I am.
Maybe it sounds kind
of schizophrenic when
you talk about it conceptually.
But for me, it works.
I don't find it to be--
in the song, it works.
And I think that has to do with
the fact that I'm from Tijuana,
and I grew up
listening to-- I mean,
my mom would sing [INAUDIBLE]
on her way to school
every morning.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
That's kind of funny.
But she did, every morning.
She'd do [? "Kri Kri" ?]
or [INAUDIBLE].
So you know, it's not so
far away from my [INAUDIBLE]
that I mix that-- a Norteno
accordion in a really
melodic sort of idea.
And I find the festivity
of the accordion
has to do with my
character, and also,
the seriousness of a piano
or the seriousness of--
And I think that we're all
telling our own stories.
I'm kind of telling my
stories in my songs.
And every story that
I tell in my lyrics,
or also musically-- the way that
I decide to dress up the song
has to do with who I am.
So yes, I think that definitely
Mexico, and also US, and also
Tijuana, and also my
family, and whatever
it is that I'm
feeling at that moment
has to do with what I'm
doing when I'm writing.
SPEAKER: Of course.
Is the accordion your
favorite instrument?
JULIETA VENEGAS: Well actually,
we'll keep this a secret.
But my favorite
instrument as a piano.
I would say that
I'm a [SPANISH].
I'm a pianist dressed up
as an accordion player.
Because I'm actually a pianist.
I write on the piano.
Actually when I
write songs now-- I
used to do it differently,
but it's always been changing.
But now, I sit down with a
piano with nothing but my phone.
And I write songs in piano.
And maybe I'll use
a drum machine,
but it's mostly just piano.
And after that, I'll start
building the song up.
And sometimes, I'll
use the accordion.
Sometimes I won't.
It's more like for arranging.
I love arranging.
And also, I love to play it on
the stage because it's so fun.
You bring out the accordion.
It's like, yeah.
It's like bringing out
like a lasso or something.
It's like woohoo.
It's really fun.
And I think that's what
the shows are about.
It's about fun and also
just kind of making it
like all different
kinds of feelings.
And I think definitely,
the accordion
brings sort of like a festive
and sort of a [SPANISH],
a joyous feeling for me.
SPEAKER: Perfect.
And don't worry.
We'll keep this a secret.
JULIETA VENEGAS: OK, thanks.
SPEAKER: Disregarding
the fact that this
is going to be posted in
Talks At Google on the YouTube
channel.
Other than that, It's a
secret between you and me.
JULIETA VENEGAS: OK.
SPEAKER: With this duality
that you're talking about--
and I think it reflects on a
lot of the music that you do.
It's the seriousness
of the piano,
but then bringing
out the accordion.
And as you mentioned,
it's like bringing a lasso
to somebody who plays the
seriousness of classic piano
music.
Is that how you
always see things?
Do you try to mix all
these different elements,
see what works better
in every single case
and then just do it?
Is that a conscious process?
Or is it just however
it's coming for you
and you feel in the moment?
JULIETA VENEGAS: Well,
we come back to the idea
that I said before.
It's intuition.
I keep letting intuition
sort of guide me.
I'm not conceptual
in that sense.
It's not like I started
writing a song and think,
this has to be
this sort of song.
And it has to finish
sounding like this.
I never really know.
It's very organic.
I always say it's like knitting.
Writing a song, you
put the verse in.
You kind of bring it
on to something else.
And it's sort of
like a live process.
You don't really know
what's going to happen.
And it happens when
I'm writing a song.
And it also happens
when I'm arranging it.
It's sort of a live thing.
And I think that's
the magic of it.
And that's why I
keep on doing it
because, it's so-- you
don't know what's going
to happen-- unpredictable.
So I think that's what
I really like about it.
I don't think that after--
I mean, now I know
that I can write.
I can sit down and write a song.
Because I used to be
like very doubtful.
I've always been a
skeptic in every sense.
So it took me years
to figure out why
people are going to my shows.
It took me years
to say yeah, OK.
Yeah, I put some albums out.
And I never really
believed the whole thing.
It's always like,
yeah, this is who I am,
but it doesn't mean that
nothing is going to happen.
And I would always say
like, well, I'm not sure
when I sit down, I'm going to
actually come up with a song.
But now, after this
time, I know that I am
going to come up with a song.
Because I like it, and I'm
going to sit there until I do.
And I'm very like-- and also
that I'm very disciplined.
When I sit down to write, I
do the 9:00 to 5:00, actually.
That's what I do.
I stop the tour.
I don't like trying to
write when I'm traveling.
When I'm traveling,
I like to read.
I read all the time.
But when I'm writing, it's
like 9:00 to 5:00 thing.
I stop for lunch.
But I-- and also
having a daughter
makes me more disciplined
in that sense.
Because it used to be when I
was going to write an album,
I could take like the
day and sort of just read
and then go to the piano.
But now I know that I have
those hours in for her.
It's also easier to say, OK,
you're done at this time,
and we can just hang out.
And for me, it's like I
can disconnect and just
be where I am.
SPEAKER: Of course.
It's funny you mentioned that.
Because at least for me, from
an external point of view--
I'm not a musician,
not a songwriter,
not an artist certainly,
even though I play piano,
but that's about it.
For a lot of people outside
this artist environment,
it sounds like it's a
matter of inspiration.
Like you're basically
walking down life.
And then inspiration comes.
And you're like, [GASP]
I need a piece of paper
and then start writing down.
But it turns out that's
not the case with you,
that you do the formal I sit
down and then at some point,
ideas are going to come.
Is that typical for
everybody who writes songs?
Is that specific to Julieta?
JULIETA VENEGAS: I think
everybody's different, too.
I don't know how other
people write songs.
I've never had that
miracle, that idea
that will just come to my head.
And [GASP] I have
a song in my head.
Let me sit down and write it.
No, I have to kind
of search for it.
And I like it that way
because at first, you're
kind of fearful
when you sit down
and you see the blank notebook.
Because also, I don't even
have lyrics when I sit down.
I write everything together.
Maybe I'll have like
one line or something,
and I'll start
working with that.
But usually, it
all comes together.
I mean, I'll just kind of
like-- I start with one line.
And that'll bring me
onto the rest of it.
And so I think other
people will-- I mean,
I'm sure there are
people who write
on tour and people who like
to wait for the songs to come.
But I like the fact that I can
sit down and find something.
Because also, if
nothing comes up,
I'll just keep on playing
the piano, which is something
that I really enjoy.
It's a different thing.
And also, I don't
like to feel like I'm
searching for the song.
I'm just like, I'm
going to play and let
it come, and that kind of thing.
But yeah, It's just that I've
always been very much in love
with the piano.
And playing the piano is also
kind of therapeutic for me.
I mean, I just kind of sit down
and improvise all the time.
I do read notes.
And I do some exercises
to warm my hands
and kind of like-- but I also
just kind of like to improvise.
SPEAKER: Perfect.
And I want to be
conscious of the time.
I think we have time.
We might open the
floor to a couple
of questions from the audience.
JULIETA VENEGAS: Oh, great.
SPEAKER: That's fine with you?
Just a quick question
before that-- what's
your favorite Julieta song?
JULIETA VENEGAS: [LAUGHS] I
don't have a favorite Julieta
song.
It's crazy.
When I finish my
album-- I'm serious.
You look at me like, oh my god.
She's crazy.
No--
SPEAKER: No, I'm curious.
That's what's going on.
JULIETA VENEGAS: OK.
Whenever I finish an album that
I-- I mean, when I'm writing,
maybe I'll have a favorite
like for a day or two.
And then I come up with another
one which is my favorite.
And then that--
But when I finish an
album, I actually--
when I'm done with the
whole writing process
and producing it, I'll
listen to it obsessively.
I'll be all day like wondering
if that's the right way
to structure it, if that's
the right way to do it,
and blah, blah, blah.
And when I'm done with it,
it's like, OK, I'm done.
That's it.
I never listen to it again.
I might listen to a song when
I'm trying to bring it back
for a show or-- but
I'm very, very lazy
about listening to my own songs.
It's like-- no, I'm serious.
It's like looking into a mirror.
You look into a mirror,
and yeah, you're
wearing makeup or whatever.
You comb your hair.
You shave or whatever.
And then that's it.
There's no surprises there.
And for me, listening
to music has to do with,
wow, how do you
come up with that?
Or, oh-- you know, just
being moved by somebody,
by their story, by
what's happening
to you at that moment.
And that happens to me
with other people's music,
not with mine.
SPEAKER: That's really funny.
OK, perfect.
Let's open it up for
audience questions.
AUDIENCE: Hola, Julieta.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
JULIETA VENEGAS:
AUDIENCE: I always say
before being a Mexican,
I am from Tijuana.
And I am the same as you.
I was born in the US
but I grew up in Mexico.
And my comment or question
is related to that.
I have the feeling
that for people
that come from Latin
American countries,
people focus on
the negative part.
And it's true.
We are not blind
to what's going on.
But there's so many things
positive about every place
in this planet that I always
find it a little bit sad.
I don't get offended
because I know.
But can you share with us
something that you really
like from Tijuana?
Like I can tell you that nothing
beats a concert in Tijuana.
Broken Espanol in Tijuana is
the best thing in the world.
JULIETA VENEGAS: No, definitely.
I think Tijuana is
a very unique place.
That's what it has--
and you don't realize it
when you're growing up
there-- but how different
it is from any other city,
either in the US or in Mexico.
It has nothing to do with-- and
not even with any other border
city.
I love border cities.
And that's something that I--
whenever I'm in a boarder city,
I feel like I can understand
the idea of living
between two countries always.
But I think definitely, Tijuana
is a very special border
because it's bordered
with California, people.
I mean, come on.
And you know, the coast is
beautiful, and the food.
The food is definitely amazing.
So yeah, I really love
having grown up there.
I don't think I could possibly
choose any other city.
Because also when I
got to Mexico City,
people found me to be a bit
of a Martian being Norteno.
Because Norteno-- people in
the north of the country,
we're very direct.
We're just like, this
is what I'm thinking.
And it comes out like that.
And in Mexico City, I had a hard
time getting adapted to the way
that people are.
They're very [SPANISH].
So they go around,
and they don't
say what they're thinking.
And Nortenos are like,
yeah, just say it.
So yeah definitely,
I think-- yeah,
and I think that the
public in Tijuana
are just like crazy and great.
And I always like--
And my family lives
there, actually.
They still live between
Tijuana and San Diego.
Part of them live in San Diego.
Some of them go to school in
Tijuana and live in Tijuana.
Others work in San Diego
and live in Tijuana.
It's kind of like both sides.
Actually, this is
the way that I would
like to end that comment,
which is a friend of mine
came with me to Tijuana
one day to visit.
She hadn't been there before.
And I was like, you
haven't been to Tijuana.
You have to come.
And she came, and she
didn't bring her passport.
I'm like, you came
without your passport?
I mean, what?
She was like, I thought
we were coming to Tijuana.
I'm like, yeah, but
going to Tijuana
is crossing to San Diego.
So I'm like, you're going to get
to know like half the city now.
It's sort of like the whole
experience kind of goes
together with [INAUDIBLE].
So yeah, she was kind of mad.
But I was like sorry,
I didn't explain.
I thought you knew.
AUDIENCE: I also am a big fan.
And I'm not from the Tijuana,
but I live in Esenada.
And I'm from Mexico City.
So I relate to many of
the things that you said.
I have two questions.
One is that you said before
that you want to educate
your child in Mexico City.
I would like to know why.
And also, if you can share
some of your favorite music,
if not favorite Julieta
song, some of your favorites
for other artists.
JULIETA VENEGAS: Well,
I think the education
part is because I love her
growing up in Mexico City.
I think it's just a
city that has so much.
We live in Coyoacan, which is
a part of the city that I love.
And sometimes she
asks me why we don't
live in the beach, which is
kind of a really big conflict.
And she's only five.
And I kind of look
at her like, what?
But we live in Mexico City.
There's no place
better than this.
And she's like, no,
there's no dolphins here.
Hello?
So we do have a bit
of-- I'm sure it's
going to come up again.
But I like the school
where she's at.
Actually, she's studying
in a bilingual school,
which I kind of like that
because I'm bilingual.
And I can relate to
her being bilingual,
although right now,
she's [SPANISH].
I'll talk to her in English,
being all like, hey,
let's practice English.
And she'll be like, si, mamma.
OK.
But I don't know.
I don't know how to explain it.
It's just this feeling
that I love Mexico City.
And I love Mexican
culture in every sense.
And I like her being bilingual.
And eventually, I think we'll
probably come to San Diego.
And we spend a lot of time
in San Diego with my parents
because they live there.
But I just like Mexico City.
I like her growing
up in a big city,
but that's just because
I love big cities.
Maybe when she grows
up, she'll be like,
I want to go to Ensenada.
And I don't know why I grew
up in Mexico City, like you.
Yeah.
Yeah, and what was
the other question?
AUDIENCE: It's, what's your--
AUDIENCE: Some of
your favorite music,
and if you can share
your favorite books.
I think that you
like a lot of books.
JULIETA VENEGAS:
Oh yeah, of course.
Oof, don't get me started.
OK, no, music, I've
been listening a lot
to-- there's a band from
Argentina who's called
Francisca & Los Exploradores.
It's very beautiful.
He's actually a guy, not a
girl, but he's Francisca.
And it's pretty beautiful.
He's pretty amazing.
There's also-- I don't know
if you know Javiera Mena.
She's from Chile, and
she's beautiful also.
[INAUDIBLE] also from Chile.
From Mexico, I'm
sure everybody knows
Carla Morrison but I love her
and I love her new album, "Amor
Supremo."
She's beautiful and talented.
Who else?
Oh, there's a band from
Mexico called [INAUDIBLE].
They're not new new, but
I know a lot of people
don't know them.
And I really recommend them.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
It's pretty great.
So those are some bands.
Books, it's just
that recently, I've
been pretty much into the
Second World War, which
is kind of not so, you know.
But there is one-- I mean,
if anybody's into it.
And if not, I really think
you should read this book.
It's not actually new, but I
just barely read it this year.
And I'm pretty amazed by it.
It's called "Life and
Fate" by Vasily Grossman.
He was in the-- it's all
about the [SPEAKING SPANISH]
between the Russians
and the Germans.
And he was there the whole time.
So he's sort of does
this panoramic view
of every single
different situation that
was affected by people
during the war, which
is pretty amazing.
And it's beautiful.
And I'm serious.
That was probably
one of the books
that I've read lately
that kind of-- it
took me awhile to get over--
like when I was done with it,
I just had this feeling of
loss of being done with it.
It was--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JULIETA VENEGAS: No, fate.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
Pretty great.
SPEAKER: We have time for-- OK.
I think we're out of time.
Julieta's on a very
tight schedule today
because we're going
to do a tour--
AUDIENCE: One more question or--
AUDIENCE: Hello, Julieta.
JULIETA VENEGAS: Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm from Peru.
I'm very excited to be here.
I have been at Google
for three weeks.
So when I [INAUDIBLE] I was, I'm
going to see Julieta Venegas.
You mentioned that
you have studied music
since you were little.
But how was the process for
you to decide that music
was going to be your career?
Like for a lot of us, we
have [INAUDIBLE] like majors.
And music is a
really hard industry
in terms of successful rate.
Before you became
famous, how did you
decide if you didn't
know if you would
be able to support yourself
in the next month, you know?
JULIETA VENEGAS:
Well actually, when
I decided that I was
going to make music,
it was totally impractical.
I was actually
like 12 years old.
And I decided that
that was my vocation.
That's what I wanted to do.
I had no idea.
At that moment, I thought I
wanted to go to conservatory
and study classical music.
And I wanted to be an
orchestra director.
And later, it
changed completely.
But that's when I decided.
That I was totally
like-- I had no idea
what was going to
happen with my life
and what way it was
going to go or anything.
I just kind of-- I knew.
It wasn't something
like a decision.
It was just sort
of like something
that came from my body.
You know, like
this is what I am.
And that was sort of like a
realization about who I was,
about my identity and
as a personal thing.
I'm a twin.
So it was very important
for me to realize that.
Because being a
twin, you're always
trying to find your
identity and who
you are and your individuality.
And I think music helped me
being who I am, in every sense.
And I think also that,
just kind of-- my sister's
a photographer, which
is kind of funny.
She's like visual and
I'm like musical, which
is we both found who we were.
And that's helped our
relationship a lot.
And what was the other question?
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: No, like
how did you decide
this to be your major
in terms of your career?
JULIETA VENEGAS:
Oh, my career major.
Well also, that was
funny, because I had
no idea what I was going to do.
I mean, my idea of
going to university,
I wanted to study
ethomusicology, which is not
at all what I'm doing now.
So I guess it was just like the
idea of going to the university
to study music, that
was an idea that I had.
Then I went to Mexico
City and I started
teaching English when I
had never studied grammar.
It's kind of funny.
But it's not so funny.
Never do that.
But I needed a job, and
I my accent was pretty,
you know-- oh, you're
practically Californian, yeah.
So yeah, I just kind
of taught English.
And that's what I did
for the first year.
And then my first musical job
was to do music for a play.
And so that was my first job.
But yeah, it was
hard in the beginning
because my parents were
pretty much like, oh, you're
leaving to Mexico City.
Great.
I'm not going to help you.
And I was like, OK,
OK, OK, I'll do this.
I can do this.
I got this.
And yeah, the first
year was pretty tough.
But yeah-- and you know, I had
no idea it was going to happen.
I mean, maybe eventually
I could have given up.
And I could have said--
And actually at one point,
I was about to give up.
All my family pitched
in for a ticket for me
to come spend Christmas
with them, which
was kind of sweet--
except my dad, of course.
He was still mad.
But I had this
conversation with my mom.
And I said, mom, I don't
think I can do this.
I mean, I'm going to go back.
I don't know how I'm
going to pay the rent.
This is like a struggle.
I'm alone.
I don't really know anybody.
This is too much for me.
And my mom was like,
don't come back.
I mean, you have--
every time I say this,
I kind of want to cry.
She's like [SPANISH].
Don't come back.
I mean, I've never told you
this, but my dream in life
was to be a singer,
and I never did it.
And you're doing it.
I'm like-- I mean, I
hadn't done anything.
But for me, that
was the best push
that she could have given me.
And then they pitched in to help
me pay the rent that month--
pretty cool. [LAUGHS]
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Once again, thank
you very much for this.
This was fantastic-- very
honest, very original, very
you.
Thank you very
much for this chat.
And let's give one more
round of applause to Julieta.
JULIETA VENEGAS:
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]